says power failure the new book she
co-wrote with Texas Monthly executive
editor Mimi Swartz it's behind the
scenes look at the collapse of the gas
and energy trading company the program
runs about 45 minutes good evening and
thank you for coming I would like to
welcome you to a discussion with Mimi
Schwartz and Sharon Watkins they will
discuss their book power failure the
infant story of the collapse of Enron
Sharon Watkins is known as the Enron
whistleblower and one of Time Magazine's
2002 Person of the Year
Mimi Schwartz is an executive editor at
Texas Monthly and has won a national
magazine award in the Public Interest
category in 1996
we will start with meanie Schwartz
telling us more about her book and then
proceed with Sharon Watkins afterwards
we will have a question-and-answer
session if you would like to ask a
question please go to the microphone so
that everyone else can hear when all the
questions are finished we will start the
signing now let's get started please
welcome
Mimi Schwartz I'd like to thank you all
very much for coming the way we've been
doing this is I've been doing a short
reading so you can get a feel for the
book and then Sharon was going to talk
about the book and her life so I will
start this is the preface to the book we
I wanted the book to be a Houston story
because this is where I live and I
thought the book Illustrated could be
used to illustrate a lot of aspects of
Houston life and culture so this chapter
will give you a feel for what I was
trying to do it's called put me in Enron
for as far back as anyone could remember
since 1958 when he'd started his firm
the old money families in Houston had
referred to fire Seraphim by his first
name only as if he were a secret they
all shared these were the families whose
wealth dated back to cattle and cotton
and timber but more important they were
the families who had made their money in
oil early in the first 20 years of the
20th century to them the enigmatic
egyption with the flawless manners the
impeccably tailored suits and the modern
art collection Robert Motherwell Willem
de Kooning Christo with someone to be
respected and revered they admired his
taste in general seraphim always seemed
to know what was new and best before
they did but mostly they admired his
taste in money families who had made
their fortunes in oil knew just how
volatile the business was how quickly
prosperity could vanish through
carelessness capriciousness and
arrogance and so depended on seraphim
and his investment firm which managed
more than 40 billion in assets for
stability he was a man for whom
consistency was a daily practice
throughout 2001
for instance Seraphim ate his workday
lunch with the same woman his secretary
mrs. white at the same club the Coronado
inside the old Bank of the Southwest
building at the same table
adjacent to the giant television screen
tuned routinely to see nbc's market
reports he was neither handsome nor
particularly unhandsome in late middle
age he was balding and portly his eyes
and lips were narrow and he wore glasses
with heavy square frames like many
prominent Houstonians seraphim had
endured some volatility in his personal
portfolio his 250 million dollar divorce
from Louisa studi an heiress to one of
Houston's great fortunes had made news
so at the revelation of his semi secret
life the requisite parallel Texas family
that included mistress child and so on
but Seraphim rarely spoke to the press
his lawyers advised against it and the
stories faded and he returned soon
enough to his life of carefully crafted
obscurity nervous energy is a great
destroyer of wealth Seraphim liked to
say and he lived by those words he
detested risky investments his firm's
philosophy the one that enabled it to
outperform the Standard and Poor's index
in 11 of the past 14 years was as
follows we believe that long-term stock
price appreciation is based on long-term
earnings growth sustainable earnings
growth is predicated on dominance in an
attractive industry dominant businesses
usually reside in large companies that
can produce superior earnings growth and
market leadership over long periods of
time
in 1993 the New York Times called
Seraphim a top financier with a passion
for brand names in 1997 Barron's called
him a brand name champion he liked
Johnson & Johnson he liked Procter &
Gamble he liked General Electric and
coca-cola but in the late 1990s
something happened to seraphim's loyal
clientele the bull market was raging and
they wanted him to invest their money in
a company called Enron Enron was then
the world's leading energy company by
its own account and everyone else's it's
glossy annual reports showed earnings in
the hundreds of millions and those
earnings grew by almost 20
cent every year from 1998 to 2000 the
stock price bounded from around $20 a
share to close to $90 to share and
better yet it was a Houston company the
old money crowd was very taken with
Enron CEO Ken Lay they worked with him
to raise money for the United Way and
Houston's Museum of Fine Arts they drew
up Houston's future alongside him at the
greatest at the Greater Houston
partnership and the River Oaks Country
Club
Ken Lay was a good man they insisted he
knew what he was doing by Enron put me
in Enron it was like a fever that if
Seraphim had been in Houston in the oil
craze 1920s might have seemed familiar
but Seraphim was immune to such
entreaties nervous energy is a great
destroyer of wealth and he would refuse
his explanation was very simple I can't
understand their balance sheets he said
grumbling his clients would listen nod
their heads and retreat but they were
sure they were losing out on the deal of
the century and so would call again and
demand the stock by Enron put me in
Enron and again Seraphim in that soft
calm resolute voice would refuse he
didn't put his clients in anything he
didn't invest in himself and he wasn't
investing in Enron he made the mad fires
was getting old the children and
grandchildren and great-grandchildren of
the wildcatters complained fires
couldn't see the future when it was
staring him in the face
he was mired in the past too damned
old-fashioned biased they said just
doesn't get it thank you
now I'd like to introduce my great
partner Sharon watt
well I do appreciate all you coming out
on this pre holiday weekend
I was going to have just a handful of
remarks about my my time at Enron but
also the process of writing the book
with me me and what what our goals were
really in in doing the book first off I
had been at Enron not quite eight years
when I changed jobs went back to work
for Andy fast down in the summer of 2001
I was doing a really simple job it was
called commercial support work so I
could get home to be with my
two-year-old daughter and so my travel
was not outrageous my job was simply to
prioritised the assets in ron had for
sale i was looking at book values
estimated market values seeing the
wherein ron could get the biggest bang
for the buck in selling assets raising
cash to lower debt well i stumbled
across a handful of assets that were
hedged with these raptor structures most
of you are probably aware that andy fast
down the chief financial officer of
Enron had been able to form an outside
venture he was the general partner of a
partnership he'd raised over 600 million
dollars of investment money and his
partnerships main purpose was to do
business with Enron to buy assets and to
transact with Enron the Board of
Directors had in a rather unprecedented
move waved the code of conduct for Andy
to allow him to enter into this conflict
of interest and just really what that
means is and he was chief financial
officer of Enron where his fiduciary
duty was to look look after the value of
Enron yet he was also the general
partner of this partnership called ljm
where his duties were to increase the
return for his limited partners so he
has an inherent conflict if he tries to
do the best deal for his partners in LJM
he's hurting Enron where if he's trying
to be CFO of Enron and do the best deal
for Enron
hurting his partners we all now know
from the complaint and press articles
that when it came time to make a
decision Andy favored LJM and not Enron
I believe he Mimi's got it in the in the
book we might even want to quote it
directly from the book but his
investment in the first ljm was
something like two or three million and
he made 20 million plus this is under a
year his investment in the second ljm
was three to five million and he made 20
million plus his total take-home was
something like fifteen fifty three or
forty to fifty million from these
partnerships that's just an incredible
return for your money he let in some of
his buddies from Enron a couple people
invested five thousand eight hundred
dollars within a month they got a
million dollars that's quite and we talk
about money growing on trees it's
falling out of the sky at that point so
we now all are very aware of Andy's
shenanigans but I happen to none of us
knew about that kind of money that they
were making what I stumbled across were
these vehicles called the Raptors they
were subsidiaries of Andy's LJM
partnership and they had done hedging
transactions with Enron a hedge a hedge
transaction is just a transaction where
Enron has agreed to sell an asset at a
particular price to the Raptor
structures sometime in the future well
at this point the assets had declined in
value significantly over 700 million
dollars worth and what the flaws of the
Raptors were readily apparent because
come to find out they were capitalized
with nothing but a promise of future
Enron shares and Enron shares had
declined in value so that even this
flawed structure didn't have enough
value to pay Enron the 700 million
dollars that it out it I think people
that were close to this these structures
now understood their flaws but it was a
little bit too late to speak
and I quite often use the emperor's new
clothing analogy to describe what
happened at Enron in that story first
you have an emperor who's too vain
focused on his own appearance and in the
next new set of clothes and not on
running his kingdom and that really fits
Ken Lay because he'd been focused on
getting Houston a state-of-the-art
baseball stadium so we could keep the
Astros he was focused on getting George
Bush elected focused on a lot of very
wonderful community and charitable
giving but it was a distraction from his
real job which was running the company
he was not very focused on the details
of the company so what does that allow
that allows swindlers in in my opinion
the swindlers are Jeff Skilling and Andy
fast down now their swindle is quite
elaborate it's a beautiful cloth they're
weaving that has thousands of colors and
changes colors in the light but it's got
a little catch to it you can't see it if
you're either stupid or not fit for
office well that's very similar to these
Raptor structures they were highly
complex they'd put them up on a
presentation on a whiteboard and act
like well they basically say this is
cutting-edge accounting this is so
innovative this is you know this is only
because Enron hires the best and the
brightest and we've come up with these
structures and they they're going to
work magic for us and basically it was
an intimidating presentation to the
point of you get this right you're not
going to ask a question and show you're
not smart enough to understand these
structures and so a number of people
that were around when these structures
were created we're really intimidated
into not asking questions about it plus
the fact that the Raptors were really
relying on a promise of future Enron
shares was almost like a footnote that
you could ignore you know barring you
know the the problem of the underlying
assets falling
in the Emperor's New Clothes the Emperor
sends in a minister to check on the
progress of the weaving of the cloth he
steps into the building the room the
swindlers describe how gorgeous the
cloth is and he panics he says well I
know I'm not stupid but possibly I'm not
fit for my office so he lies his own
insecurities come into play and he says
he can see the cloth week later there in
persons in another Minister same thing
happens he can't see the cloth but he's
got the double pressure that the
minister before him could see the cloth
so he lies and says he can see the cloth
well in the translation I have of this
hundred and fifty year old fable right
before the emperor is about to go on the
parade naked The ministers think to
themselves individually I think we're
being swindled yet it was too late for
them to go up and say anything to the
Emperor because although the Emperor
would be very grateful that he was saved
the embarrassment of walking down the
parade route he of course would
eventually fire them because they lied
to him in the first place and that is
such a perfect analogy I think for what
happened at Enron Jeff Skilling when I
found these Raptor structures my first
reaction was that this was horrible
accounting fraud it was a misstatement
of our earnings in 2000 that amounted to
over 50 percent of our net income
pre-tax over a third of our net income
after tax it was a very significant
fraud and I wanted to just get out of
there as fast as I could I started
interviewing with other companies and my
intention was to confront Jeff Skilling
on my last day well he beat me to the
punch and resigned
August 14th 2001 that really let me know
that things were way worse than I even
thought
and I reacted really out of a gut
reaction that this was horribly unfair
for Ken Lay to be coming out of
retirement stepping back in as CEO
and he had no idea what it what had
really happened to his company in the
last several years so I wanted to warn
him but I also wanted Enron to do the
right thing which in my mind was to
restate financial statements come clean
really confess that you've done
something wrong accrue two billion
dollars on the balance sheet for
shareholder litigation and really form a
crisis management team to try to address
the problems that always happen to a
company when you when you're accused of
cooking the books well Ken light turns
to all the executives that are around
him to say could she be right and you
can see this for yourself and all the
Vinson & Elkins interview notes almost
all these executives say don't ask me I
can't judge for myself as to whether or
not you've got on close or Arthur
Andersen is the expert I would just go
ask them I've got no expertise in this
arena so he was able with no one else
backing me up he was able to gravitate
towards the good news Vinson & Elkins
did a very limited scope review of my
concerns and the company I think did one
of the worst things they could possibly
do on October 16 2001 they just unwound
these Raptor transactions that I was so
concerned with that resulted in almost a
700 million dollar hit to the income
statement and a 1.2 billion dollar
reduction of shareholders equity and the
explanation was it was an unwind of a
previously disclosed transaction well
that didn't quite fly you know investors
and the financial community they
understand when you make bad business
decisions when you pay too much for an
asset or a company and you have to write
it down they understand when you invest
too much in telecom and the whole sector
craters and you have writedowns
they don't understand an unwind of a
transaction that's kind of like saying
we want to do over we're going to have a
never mind on that transaction please
well that would be fine if it didn't
result in huge losses but to say you
want a do-over never mind let's pretend
we never did that did these transactions
but oh by the way that's called
700 million dollars in our income
statement and 1.2 billion in our
shareholders equity
well it sure makes investors think was
that you're writing this off because it
was in your income earlier you know
what's what's the story here all the
uncertainty really had Enron spiraling
out of control there were three front
page expose articles in The Wall Street
Journal on October 17th 18th and 19th
the day Enron made the earnings
announcement the stock closed at $33 it
opened at about thirty three dollars a
day so kind of remained holds hold
October 17th on it marched steadily
downward and by the end of November it
was I think 11 cents a share and the
company declared bankruptcy December 2nd
it was such a fast spiral out of control
but the alarming thing for so many of us
that worked at Enron was the depth of
the moral bankruptcy of the company
because on December 3rd Enron laid off
over 4,000 people three weeks before
Christmas with with nothing with a hint
and a promise at a four thousand dollar
severance check which doesn't get you
very far
a hint and a promise that you could buy
your own Cobra insurance if the
bankruptcy judge approved a payment to
the insurance company you know and all
these employees heard last Friday was
your last paycheck go back to your desk
clear out your personal items and go
come to find out in January 2002 it was
disclosed that nearly 25 executives
well 25 executives paid themselves
nearly 55 million dollars the last week
before bankruptcy one person got 8
million another person five million a
couple people got 1.5 million
there were several 750 thousand dollar
amounts now this was to stay at the
company for three months till the end of
February
now that was that was just an outrageous
amount of money to stay for 3 months
these executives gave themselves a three
to five year
if their annual base pay usually didn't
run the maximum base pay was about two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars so
these executives gave themselves quite a
large cushion and then had the gall to
stand up in front of thousands of other
employees and say you know bye-bye
it's three weeks before Christmas sorry
you don't have anything more from us you
know it's been great working with you
sorry to have to do this and that's
outrageous I just think those those top
guys that made the decision to do such
large bonuses or just as crooked as Andy
Fastow
they stuck their hand in that cash
drawer the week before bankruptcy and
piled as much cash in their pockets as
they could and that was so alarming now
of course that was in the press there's
been a deferred compensation scandal
there's been various scandals but but
actually part of the reason for doing
the book on my behalf
was to show a real human story of how
many good smart people could see warning
signs but still stay and so me me using
me as a character in the book and as she
shows that even as early as 96 I saw
some aggressive accounting that made me
very uncomfortable however when the
stock price is rising your pay is good
the business trips are lavish and when
your business leaders your your top guys
are on the front page of Businessweek or
Forbes or fortune it's it's really easy
to say you know I'm gonna put those
nagging concerns behind maybe I just
don't get it you know maybe I'm just a
little old-fashioned in my accounting
theories and the world is changing and
it's very easy to stick with that
company and I'll give you a for instance
of that the most recent corporate
scandal is HealthSouth and turns out
they've been cooking their books since
their inception 15 years ago now because
of the inrun scandal the sorbets Oxley
Act was passed in July 2002 and it now
makes it criminal to knowingly push out
misleading financial statements the top
executives have to sign financial
statements certifying
that that they have no knowledge you
know that of misleading information in
the financial statements well there are
two guys at HealthSouth that still sign
those financial statements and I don't
know whether it was arrogance that they
just wouldn't get caught but there are a
number of people that have already pled
guilty to financial statement fraud in
that case and when you read about
HealthSouth it's like a a mirror story
of Enron their top CEO which I think you
pronounce his name
scroll she he sounds like a combination
Ken Lay Jeff Skilling the company's
based in Birmingham Alabama a small town
he gave very generously to the community
the community just loves him so in that
instance he's like Ken Lay but he was
also like Jeff Skilling he's described
as hypnotic charismatic had a cult-like
following from his employees and like
Jeff Skilling he hired every younger
people paid them more than they ever
thought they would ever make treated
them to lavish business trips and it
bought a lot of company loyalty it
bought a lot of people you know into
really second-guessing themselves and
looking the other way so the the reason
I was interested in working with me
Mia's she had done a story on Enron in
the fall of 2001 for Texas Monthly and I
really felt like she had captured the
culture and the spirit I mean you felt
like you were in the building and I
wanted to be able to explain and work
with someone that could explain the
morality tale here explain how so many
good people and bright people could be
sucked into it and I hope that you will
enjoy the book I also would really
welcome questions not just of me and my
in on experiences but also of Mimi and
she interviewed hundreds of Enron people
and her experiences too and in meeting
all of these Enron employees thanks
thank you
oh okay we're gonna start the question
answer segment now if you have a
question to answer ask a question to ask
if you would come over to the microphone
over here and ask it that would be great
or they could ask and I could just
repeat it - if you're more comfortable
that we're staying seated yeah that's
good we can do that that's great that
sounds great okay
all right yeah this is a Mimi how did
y'all split up the work in terms of
interviewing people but the heavy load
is right here I had my own list and then
Sharon supplemented it and then every
time almost every time I had an
interview with somebody I'd go back to
her and tell her what I knew and we sort
of fitted into a structure that we had
in our minds for a bit sort of the
general narrative structure a a few but
it wasn't that hard it was so much
harder to get people to talk for the
story I wrote in October for Texas
Monthly then once the company had fallen
people were so angry they did kind of
come out of the woodwork so but there
was certainly things that Mimi would
start with the white page and then send
chapters to me that that I would add a
revise she was charging on ahead as she
finished then she'd come back through
and and re rework what I had added in to
you know use it not use some of it but
there were some things I'd say oh my
goodness where'd you get this and she'd
say well I can't reveal my sources
yeah but Sharon also had great files and
great institutional memory I mean there
was one clipping from 95 about a Jeff
Skilling being led out of the building
in handcuffs it was a false rumor it
never been you know all these reporters
that come down here and come through
everything but it just worked out it fit
perfectly in the story we were trying to
tell I was a I'm a pet pack so I had um
yeah service had great files which I
think again gave this story so much more
dimension
what how are Enron Enron folks writing
I've had some people say it all reads
pretty truthfully twice well any other
questions all right well that's you know
I think they repeat Jim asked us what I
have really gone to Jeff Skilling you
know just to let you know how
intimidating he was you know it was my
intention to do that and one day I was
going from one elevator bank to another
walking in front of that Starbucks you
know stand and he comes back this way
you know hi Sharon hi Jeff and I thought
oh you're just singing I don't know if
I'm gonna be able to get up the courage
to go tell him even on my last day but I
think I would have and then you know
would the only the only thing I can
think of is his concern that I was out
there working for another company and
would I tell my news to the SEC you know
would it have forced him to try to clean
it up but then again I think he's
rationalizing his behavior he was able
to testify in front of Congress like
that because he firmly believes he had
no one's interest in mind but the
shareholders keep that stock price going
up because that's good for the
shareholders now they're all left with
stock worth 20 cents or nine cents or a
nickel and he's sold out 66 million
dollars worth in the last year that's a
little hard to take but I don't know it
would have been tough it would have been
tired
we spent time with them the question the
question was what about Doubledays legal
department and this the story was lawyer
very carefully I mean they read it they
had a very nice lawyer there who read it
pretty carefully the wonderful thing
about that is truth is the ultimate
defense so when you make sure you
haven't printed any lies yeah he should
prevail yeah and there was I mean the
good thing is there was a lot of
documentation for some of these things
interes testimony before the Senate and
stuff like that and also all of the
powers report the Board of Directors
finally did the right thing and in late
October added a new board member
Dean powers the UT laud law Dean and he
hired or this special committee hired
Wilmer Cutler and Pickering out of New
York and Deloitte and Touche spent four
million dollars three months
interviewing all these people poring
through documents and their interview
notes or this high and you know we we
got all of those all in itself and so
right you've got oh that the one thing
we should have printed has been glistens
whining about you know well don't he's
one of the people that invested five
thousand eight hundred and got a million
a month later and in his interview notes
he's like well that's really not that
much of a big return you should go look
at Enron international those guys got
big big big payments for those power
plants they did internationally you
think oh my goodness that wasn't fraud
that wasn't a good hard work that's
crazy stuff
you're talking about the dolphin
chattering yes but yes
yes this he was asking the question
about a comment I made on a radio
program about the Yahoo message chatroom
and if you go into yahoo yahoo finance
type in any company's symbol you get a
whole you get all this information on
that company that publicly traded
company and you can then click through
to a message or chatroom and four
actually at least since nineteen ninety
nine maybe earlier there was always a
lot of chat you could tell it was in ron
employees that had made like fake names
for themselves cute and clever names
they were logging on after hours from
home and really sending messages you
know to stay away from the stock this is
a short that mimi has a quote in the
book directly from one of the yahoo chat
rooms where a person said you know Enron
has done the worst fraud in years the
executives will be led away in handcuffs
and this was in once a 99 or 2000 it was
a long time ago and it so there were all
that's that's really your best defense
when you are a board of directors is to
make sure there's some way of getting
employee feedback because employees
don't like to be surrounded by
dishonesty and enough accountants were
junior levels seeing this not liking it
enough finance people we're at junior
levels seeing this not liking it and
they were venting their frustrations on
that yahoo message chat board and just
to give you a for instance when i was
doing research for some of the speeches
that i'm doing
I looked up WorldCom and WorldCom is now
the largest bankruptcy in US history but
it was a very simple fraud they moved
expenses from the income statement to
the balance sheet they have it involved
less than a half a dozen people in the
CFO's office in a very short period of
time all have pled guilty except scott
sullivan the CFO who is trying to fight
it and i went back in and traced
email chains all the way back there's no
hint of any kind of problem in
WorldCom's message room because it
wasn't that pervasive it was
to six people in the CFO's office that
were making top-level entries and
granted that companies in bankruptcy
because of that fraud but they're likely
to come out any month now they're there
they have had layoffs but the whole
telecom sector has had layoffs and that
company will still remain healthy they
have all their businesses intact and
they will emerge from bankruptcy with
the majority of their employees still
employed and with shareholders still
getting something at the end of the day
now with with at least I think so now
with Enron the shareholders are going to
get nothing creditors are going to get
cents on the dollar and it will not
emerge from bankruptcy so that's a very
last resort place to look but I think it
is telling and it tells boards of
directors that they need a way to get
anonymous feedback from employees and
investigate when the chatter gets that
loud
that's what
you kind of stay to the case of Red Rock
I don't want to say clan but I mean it's
a it's a pretty powerful force in itself
why didn't people just that's well a
hard thing to do no I think they were
sayin he's actuated with the trappings
of the job with the salaries and you
were told you were the smartest person
you know you were working for the
smartest company in town therefore you
or one of the smartest people in town I
think things like that were really
seductive but also in reading the book
you will see where a number of employees
made complaints to their managing
director bosses but it didn't go
anywhere and you know they were that
could be because those managing
directors were part of a performance
unit plan that was that paid them 65
managing directors received over 300
million dollars in bonus payments in
February 2001 based off the fact that
the stock price outperformed the top S&P
companies for three years ending in 2000
98 99 2000 so were those managing
directors incentivize not to rock the
boat but what happens when people speak
up like Vince Kaminsky he goes back to
his department and says I got nowhere
well that reverberates throughout the
organization that you better not speak
up because you know Vince one of our hot
most highly respected executives did and
it got nowhere but me me points this out
in the book and this is the way you felt
to to to go in 2000 and start
interviewing I I saw this in 2001 when I
started interviewing you've got that
little bit of a suspicion now why are
you leaving in wrong I mean it was the
hot place to work and people assumed
that you were really being pushed out
not that you were choosing to leave
voluntarily and you start but but also
people left Vince Kaminsky's right-hand
person left so we just don't know how
many hundreds
good get close to this see it and leave
the question was whether or not the
changes in laws and at the SEC that have
happened because of the Enron scandal
will prevent future Enron scandals well
I think once we see executives going to
jail particularly because of the sorbets
Oxley Act and HealthSouth recent fraud
it will start to change behavior
certifying the financial statements by
top executives is a great requirement no
longer can executives hide behind the
fact that well I just didn't know the
details so if they can actually go to
jail which they fear I mean if you make
a hundred million dollars and you have
to pay a fine of 50 well so what you're
still filthy rich you know but if you
have to go to jail for a couple years
that's a whole different ballgame and
that scares top executives to death and
I can almost see CEOs marching down to
their accounting departments and saying
I don't want any aggressive accounting
I mean Ken Lay was even saying it near
the end he goes you know let's plain
vanilla is just fine I don't think we
need to think outside the box that often
let's just go back to plane but now
accounting well that's what CEOs are
going to stress when they know it's
potential jail time if they push out
misleading financial statements so I
think that was actually very helpful
where there okay clear you mean from
jail time well I think it's very telling
that Jeff Skilling did not sign any of
the ljm approval sheets he rarely never
did not find something that required his
signature and because he left his
fingerprints off this that's almost a
telling sign but he also claimed in
front of Congress that he really
couldn't recall the restructuring of the
wraptor transactions the first quarter
of 2001 and so he might actually be put
in jail on perjury because there's going
to be a whole line of witnesses that
that say it was very important to him he
came down off the 50th floor and came
down to our floor and talk to us about
it
you know that was so rare he'd never
done that before ever you know so once
you line up in front of a jury all these
witnesses that are saying I remember it
being very important to him
it's hard for him to say I wasn't aware
of that transaction it's very well
documented that he knew about those
transactions so be interesting to see
what he has to say
the bankruptcy attorneys seem to well
it's just an interesting question
Oh would we care to comment about the
bankruptcy attorneys and and the answer
is yes it's just interesting to me that
the culture of the company has been
consistent from beginning to end that I
can't remember the figure do you know
it's it's some oh there's founded number
it is the high it's the most costly
bankruptcy in US history it's it's
closing in on five hundred million
dollars every single law firm that gets
some sort of project immediately just
expands the scope the current examiner
Neil Batson and his firm are billing
eight to ten million dollars a month and
they're not the highest billing law firm
but they have expanded their scope
they're acting like the Department of
Justice and prosecutors they're
subpoenaing witnesses bankers documents
and it's like their mission in life is
just to advise the inrun estate who they
should sue in order to recover funds
should you sue certain top executives do
you have a case should you sue certain
bankers that kind of aided and abetted
Enron and their financial statement
schemes should you sue Vinson & Elkins
for malpractice it's supposed to point a
roadmap on who to sue but they're going
so far as to you know really be doing
the Department of Justice's job on who
should go to jail they're taking it too
far but the problem is as I mentioned
WorldCom is likely to emerge so all
those bankruptcy consultants are working
hard and fast to get WorldCom out of
bankruptcy Enron is a big fat meaty dead
carcass that will never live again and
it's got these vultures just fighting
each other over how many of them can can
get a big piece of the meat and then and
if the company has five billion dollars
in cash now it's got the billion and
liabilities but that's a lot of cash and
you see these guys they stay at the Four
Seasons the most expensive hotel in town
when they could stay at the Doubletree
which is nice enough and it's connected
to the building via a walkway they've
got limos waiting for them going back
and forth
kept one of the corporate jets so that
they don't have to worry with commercial
traffic back and forth from New York
it's really outrageous and the New York
bankruptcy judge isn't helping matters
as one the Houston Chronicle had a great
article where an employee was quoted
that the judge is counting nickels but
he's letting dollars pour out the door
he he denied Enron paying four million
dollars a feat at four million dollars a
year in fees to administer the existing
retirement plan and the retirement plan
still has current and run employees in
it but if you're above a certain age you
can if you're above 40 you can leave it
in there for quite a long time and he
denied that it's going to be borne by
the employees yet he's letting these law
firms bill ten to twenty million dollars
a month it's just proof that that the
culture continues I think you know I
think we're going to do a slight you
know we're gonna wrap up here and do
some book signings but I think we
probably will have a little more time
for some questions and answers in just a
few minutes yes but we're just gonna
thank you all all right now for for
coming and and showing your interest in
the Enron story thank you very much that
was for c-span's benefit so what
certainly we're still alive
well that CBS movie was a little bit of
a joke the TV movie that was already
there I had a banker tell me that he
banked Enron for 12 years and he saw
more cleavage in that 2 hour movie than
he'd seen in all the 12 years
unfortunately it's still a financial
story and there is this is a morality
tale in this book but Hollywood likes to
make it so dramatic
and and so I'd rather not see any more
in Ron missions so so she took my money
yeah yeah I'll go back in the summer yes
yeah I really really enjoyed this the
deadline was a little tighter than I'd
like but aside from that it was actually
delightful really hard I mean in some
ways that I mean it was very freeing
because most magazine stories now are so
short you have to condense them to 16
double-spaced pages so in a way this was
great I think there's a do you know this
that Mark Twain said you know I'm
starting to write you such a long letter
but it's easier to yeah yeah shortened
to write a short one yeah so in some
ways but it was it was actually really
fun I think I think there one we're
gonna sit down it's like yeah we can
certainly answer questions as y'all are
coming through - thank you
for more information on power failure by
Sharon Watkins and Mimi Schwarz visit
the publishers website
Random House dot-com slash Doubleday